peinture et pose de parquet dans cet
appartement un chantier de reprise pour
khaled salariés au sein de cette société
spécialisée dans le revêtement en arrêt
depuis le 17 mars l'entreprise a relancé
son activité depuis le lundi 27 avril au
nord de haulotte tout ce qu'il faut
qu'on comme le démasquer les jmj l on
travaille dispense un intranet réunir
entre les deux réorganisations du
planning replanification de chantier
prévue ultérieurement et équipements
sanitaires pour ses salariés le
dirigeant de cette entreprise du
bâtiment à préparer la reprise qu'on a
repris des chantiers qu'on avait laissé
un peu en stand by
d'autres pas parce qu'on n'a pas
l'accord de nos clients pour pouvoir les
reprendre ces chantiers là tant que la
date de déconfinement est pas prononcée
en l'occurrence on a on doit compter sur
la bonne volonté de nos clients et de
nos salariés aussi c'était important
pour des questions de trésorerie ni plus
ni moins parce que ça devenait compliqué
pour nous à gérer même si on a essayé de
bénéficier des dispositifs de l'état on
a on avait une trésorerie qui nous
permettait quand on a quand on a su
qu'on allait devoir fermer on avait une
trésorerie qui nous permettait grosso
modo de tenir un mois un peu plus d'un
mois
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire sa
société a obtenu le chômage partiel pour
ses salariés et bénéficier d'un prêt
garanti par l'état pour préparer la
reprise julien blanchard a organisé une
réunion avec ses 15 l employé l'objet de
la réunion d'hier c'était de de les
former entre guillemets les sensibiliser
sur les gestes barrières et la sécurité
qui va falloir mettre encore plus en
oeuvre que d'habitude sur les chantiers
à venir
actuellement 40 % de son effectif a
repris une activité tous les
collaborateurs devraient revenir au
travail à partir du 11 mai